des territoires du nord ouest à la baie
james le pin gris est une espèce
caractéristiques de la forêt boréale et
pour se reproduire ils comptent sur un
allié étonnant le feu mais qu'en est il
des populations de pin gris qui pousse
beaucoup plus au sud où les incendies de
forêt se font rares des chercheurs
tentent de percer ce mystère
[Musique]
plus jeune avec avec mes parents on se
promenait dans le kamouraska en mois
menée dans un sentier puis j'avais
observé ces peuplements de pins gris qui
détonnait avec l'environnement puis je
me suis un peu demandé ce qu'il faisait
là parce que c'est inusité de trouver
cette espèce loeb dans la région sachant
que le peintre et une espèces
typiquement boréale qui doit passer au
feu fréquemment mais la question de la
présence de ces peuplements le moment
fortement intrigué
aujourd'hui guillaume de la fontaine et
chercheur à l'université du québec à
rimouski et il a fait du pain gris son
objet d'étude avec ses étudiants il veut
comprendre pourquoi cette espèce que
l'on trouve habituellement à des
latitudes nordiques se retrouve au sud
du fleuve saint laurent sur les cas
bouron du kamouraska ces petites
collines qui ponctuent le paysage
pourquoi est-ce que le pingre et est
actuellement présent dans la région de
kamouraska qui c'est au bas saint
laurent alors que tout semble indiquer
que il ne veut pas être présent au
touquet ne devait pas pour se maintenir
par rapport aux et les noms de feu qu'on
observe actuellement c'est que le pin
gris se reproduit grâce aux feux de
forêt la chaleur intense du feu fait
fondre la cire qui scelle les cônes
libérant ainsi les graines qu'ils
contiennent c'est ce qu'on appelle le
sirop cynisme
dans le cycle 2 fera ses co va permettre
un maintien de la population de pin gris
mais un cycle de feu plus long
éventuellement on les modèles nous
indique qu' après 220 ans en feu le
pingre et complètement exclue des
populations pour comprendre la présence
du pin gris au kamouraska l'équipe de
guillaume doit d'abord estimé depuis
quand cette espèce est présente dans la
région et pour ce faire romain cloître
pierre étudie l'historique des feux de
forêt nous avons prélevé des
échantillons de sol en sait peu plus
long forestier qu'on va ensuite tamisée
trier pour en extraire les potentiels
charbon et donc c'est charbon une fois
qu'ils sont extraits on pourrait
identifier à l'aide d'un microscope et
donc on va être capable de déterminer
quelles espèces à brûler
et les résultats parlent
on a fait une courbe qui va montrer
justement les événements différents
événements de feu en fonction d'eux des
datations qu'on a reçu mes premiers
résultats montrent que on a différentes
dates qui vont apparaître on a plusieurs
charbon de pin gris qui vont présenter
des dates assez récente donc au cours
des 200 dernières années ce qui nous
paraît assez logique puisqu'on sait
qu'au cours des 200 dernières années
avec le développement humain la
colonisation et l'industrialisation il
ya eu plus de fun où on voit le pas il
grille était présent depuis depuis
longtemps mais avec un sac de feuilles
beaucoup plus lent gascon qu'est ce qui
permettrait son métier en fait on a
aussi trouvé des datations des charbons
en tout cas qui date d'hier plusieurs
milliers d'années jusqu'à plus de 5000
ans donc ça peut déjà aller dans le sens
de l'hypothèse comme quoi le pin gris
potentiellement rester sous forme de
petits peuplement isolé localement au
sommet de certains cabourg
[Musique]
le pin gris persiste donc dans la région
ce qui suggère que cet arbre est capable
de se régénérer sans feu emmanuel
pelletier cherche à comprendre sa
stratégie de survie et c'était là une
tenue qu'elle trouve sa réponse
donc c'est lui
dans la région de kamouraska en fait on
peut voir que les comptes sont ouverts
même s'il n'ya pas le feu dans la région
ok dans les armes on voit qu'il ya des
combats est fermée puisque c'est une
variante que normalement ce qu'on voit
dans la forêt boréale il sait combien de
ces retenues ce moment de
emmanuel et muriel hamas ensuite des
branches avec des comptes fermés pour le
laboratoire
en mettant les condos four on peut le
savoir iny sauve à quelle température
donc à quelle température la cuisine
qu'il ya à faire nouveau fondre film on
voulait voir si un différence entre les
populations marchi depuis les
populations en forêt boréale ont peu de
la température qui est nécessaire pour
ouvrir les comptes en les mettant au
fond on peut voir quand je regarde leurs
niveaux d'ouverture à chaque température
donc finalement ce qu'on a vu c'est que
les combats la marcheuse bien s'ouvrir
les températures plus basses qui allie
compte qu'on trouve en forêt boréale
comme les contrats marchés qui ont
besoin de des températures moins élevées
pour s'ouvrir ben ils pourraient
s'ouvrir sans feu dans le fond un milieu
naturel qui donc libérer leurs graines
de retour dans les cas bouron l'équipe
cherche à comprendre les facteurs qui
influencent cette température
d'ouverture comme le diamètre de l'arbre
son âge ou encore l'âge des cônes
est ce qu'on a observé s'il n'y avait
pas les faits la hauteur des branches ni
d'effets bel âge de la vie par contre on
a vu un effet de leur diamètre donc les
individus qui ont des plus petits
diamètres lyon les couleurs qu'on
s'ouvre à des températures plus basses
en laboratoire comme les diamètres sont
plus petits de produire des comptes qui
vont s'ouvrir les températures plus
basses à peut permettre de faire plus de
pain cris d'enfants pour densifier la
population il y avait aussi l'effet de
l'âge qu'on a pu observer donc en fait
se sait et ça a été l'inversé de ce à
quoi on s'attendait les comptes plus
vieux s'ouvrir à des températures plus
élevées ce qui suggère qu'au sein d'un
même arbre les cônes s'ouvriront à des
températures différentes selon leur âge
les tongs arrive à maturité ils peuvent
s'ouvrir des températures qui sont plus
basses donc sans feu puis si on peu eu
l'occasion d'ouvrir ils vont rester
fermés puis a intégré la banque de
graines de l'arbre dans l'éventualité où
il y aurait un feu d'enfer leur permet
de se reproduire on peut de deux façons
avec et sans feu
il ya deux choses qui explique le
changement au niveau d'un caractère dont
on parle le col ouvert où le confirmer
donc c'est l'environnement et la
génétique d'emploi il des choses des
études qui ont été faites pour des
petits cousins de pain là donc le pain
tordu dans l'ouest canadien où le pin
d'alep tu en europe on sait que le xiii
du séronais et héritable maintenant ça
nous porte à croire que celui aussi qui
est intéressant dans le fait étape ce
trailer c'est que on sait que le pin
gris ou autres ablutions ont fait une
analogie pour d'autres avouent être
capable de répondre dans un
environnement changement pour étudier la
génétique du pin gris
muriel deslauriers récolte des aiguilles
pour en extraire l'adn en laboratoire le
vin milla ici au québec y avait un grand
couvert des classes alors toutes les
espèces étaient réfugiés plus au sud
et elles ont dû faire une migration post
glaciaire au fur et à mesure des
événements de migration nordique en une
perte de diversité génétique
associations et donc potentiellement
[Musique]
les
diversité génétique responsable de cette
capacité là de se reproduire sans feu
peut être perdu nos études en génomique
vont tenter de
d'explorer cette question
tu as l'air de bien marcher pour ces
deux sets le niveau de sa marque car
leur enlever des individus
il faudra encore plusieurs années à
muriel pour comparer les gènes des pins
gris des latitudes nordiques comme ceux
de la baie james à ceux du kamouraska
c'est incroyable de savoir qu'on est
capable d'avoir différentes stratégies
donc de et cette stratégie du fait
d'être irritable donc de pouvoir la
donne et des parents aux enfants laissés
comme une erreur on a de l'avenir en
plus le pain gris de la légende
kamouraska nous sert de témoin pour
étudier les processus d'adaptation et
éventuellement de migration des plantes
en rêve en réponse aux changements
climatiques dans le fond pour éviter ou
pour voir si des plantes sont capables
d'éviter une inexorable extinction
[Musique]